It's so cringe but I'm
excited to watch it with you.
(bright upbeat music playing)
A lot of work goes into a
short late night stand-up set.
Join me, J.P. Buck as I
spotlight the comedians
who came up with some of
my favorite program sets.
This is The Set Up.
Please welcome the very
funny, Beth Stelling.
Hi Beth.
Hello. Thank you for having me, JP.
(upbeat music progressing)
This set was so long ago. You
recorded it on a flip cam.
(Beth laughing softly)
I saw that. That made
me laugh really hard.
(Buck laughing softly)
I tried to find the video
and it's like, this no longer exists.
I'm like, oh, they went
out of business I guess.
(Beth laughing loudly)
They ran out of space
of everybody capturing things
from inside their pockets.
(Buck laughing loudly)
I think that, I think it's so funny too,
like going back just to see
how I talked to you in email.
I mean, I'm not that much
different but it was just funny.
Like, you know how you always hope
that you're not like weird
or say something you regret.
Like if you go back through
Myspace message or something.
I think we were, definitely
our emails back and forth
were a little bit more
formal than they are now.
Yeah. Not my fault
bitch. I'm just kidding.
(both laughing loudly)
Why don't we just jump into
this and start watching?
Alright.
(bright upbeat music playing)
Did you just hear my pen
clicking over and over again?
I'm like,
(Beth shrieking loudly)
(laughing loudly)
I heard that. You're like, oh
no, we're gonna watch this?
It's so cringe.
(soft blaring)
But I'm excited to watch it with you.
(bright upbeat music progressing)
You walk with purpose. Look at that.
I was like, just head down,
making sure that I made it to that X.
(both laughing loudly)
That's right. They do, you do,
there is an X right there for you to hit.
You try to make it look
cool but you're just like,
it's funny that the little things
you get wrapped up in, you know?
(Buck laughing)
Cause the truth is,
like yes, you need to
hit it but you don't need
to be like right on it.
(laughing loudly)
But nothing but very different.
A little curtain, I'm
opening the curtain for you,
walking out, finding your
act and then performing
not only just for the studio audience
but knowing it's going
out to a lot of people
and gonna live on YouTube forever.
(bright upbeat music playing)
Gosh, I'm wearing those
shoes from Payless.
I have like two pairs still
left in my mom's house.
And then those are like
H&M, like capri pants.
That's like the equivalent of a male
(Buck laughing loudly)
wearing shorts on Conan.
I recently moved from
Illinois to California
and I think that you would be hard pressed
to find anybody here tonight
who's done something that brave,
(audience laughing softly)
but I did.
And I just got some news
for my sister back home.
She and her boyfriend
accidentally planned a baby.
(audience laughing progressing)
I am cringing.
Okay. Sorry.
It's making me like giddy in a bad way.
(both laughing softly)
I just think it's to put-on.
But I'm a freaking 25-year-old,
you know what I mean?
Like this is on there forever.
You get to see me like
this and now I've changed
but it's up there forever.
(both laughing loudly)
I just wouldn't do it more subtly.
You know I don't like,
I don't love like anything too put-on.
You know it's hard to avoid that.
I think early on in your career
in a short set like this.
I would do it differently
now but I liked what she did.
I love how I'm treating her
like a different person.
(laughing loudly)
(bright upbeat music playing)
I just went out and got an IUD.
No sir, not a urinary tract infection.
(audience laughing softly)
It's an intrauterine device.
And it's birth control, lasts five years,
goes right in your uterus.
It's the only time I'll say uterus.
Ah, said it again.
(audience laughing loudly)
(Beth laughing loudly)
So I went in for my consultation
and the lady was like,
Beth, everything looks good.
A fun fact, didn't know if you knew this,
but your uterus is
actually tilted backwards.
Did you know that?
I was like, okay.
So what you're telling me is
even my uterus is like, mm mm.
(audience laughing loudly)
It's the first time I've seen
a uterus with personality.
Oh yeah, yeah.
(Buck laughing loudly)
No, that's true.
I do like that joke like
I said at the beginning.
I've added a line since, I
don't like how I made her voice
but this is, now I'm just
tearing myself apart.
But um, when she says your
uterus is tilted backwards,
did you know that?
And I added a line later that
says, don't know how I could.
You never stop tinkering with material.
Yeah I'm always tinkering.
We'd literally had like set
a date to tape the special
just so you would stop tinkering.
Like that was the only way
you would stop.
(Beth laughing loudly)
(audience clapping loudly)
That was great.
Thank you.
That was fun.
Thank you very much.
Thanks so much.
Great job, Beth Stelling. Very funny.
I was like, it's so cool
he's walking over. Oh my God.
I felt like really excited
that he was walking over.
And I don't know if it's
cause like, I don't know.
I didn't think, even my head
I probably imagine bombing
and him sitting at the
desk like, you know,
(Buck laughing loudly)
but
it doesn't feel real I guess.
So when he came over and shook my hand,
I was like, can't believe this is real.
And even still, I was like
waiting for it to air that night,
like maybe it's not gonna air.
(bright upbeat music playing)
Do you see a good one?
It's almost like you're going like,
(mild clattering)
(Buck laughing loudly)
You're like...
How far do I scroll down?
How far can I get before
it says like, die?
I pulled a few that I
need to share with you.
(Beth laughing)
Oh no. Okay.
farflungfloyd said,
I'm going to assume that
she's stoned out of her mind.
It's just my like, like I said, it's my,
that's just how it comes out of me.
I get up there and I'm
like I feel the pressure
and I'm just like stay calm.
Just do your thing.
Eden Shizzle said, reminds
me of Kate McKinnon
had a child with Chelsea
Handler and Melissa Villasenor.
Interesting. That's a
wide range of people.
I like it.
(Buck laughing)
(bright upbeat music progressing)
Over to my right, you've
got Kevin Nealon watching,
which did actually make me feel good.
It didn't make me feel
the risks. He's so great.
And I can't remember if it
was before or after my set,
he introduced me to his
parents that were there.
So that made me feel so good.
And they were very kind.
And Kevin came over to me after
Conan did and he was like,
ooh, I love your style. You're so unique.
I wrote it down somewhere
so I can't remember the exact quote.
But I remember writing it down
to remember what Kevin said to me.
And then since I've got
to do shows with them
at the Laugh Factory and stuff
and he just emailed me
yesterday about Girl Daddy
and he said such kind things.
So like I always have a special place
for Kevin Nealon in my heart.
And if you remember,
Ben Stiller was there.
Like yeah.
So it said Beth Stelling
on my dressing room
and then next to it, Ben Stiller.
And I took a picture next
to the Ben Stiller one
'cause BS, you know.
But um, our initials.
And so then we were shooting
something for whatever it is,
The Incredible Life of Walter Mitty,
that movie that he was in?
Where he's on Conan and in the movie?
So I like got to be there for
that too which was so cool.
And Ben walked by me and
said something nice too.
And I was like, my mind was blown.
You know like, oh my God,
I can't believe I met Ben Stiller
and Kevin Nealon
and J.P. Buck.
(Buck laughing loudly)
It's cool to think
obviously, eight years later,
that you guys and Conan
produced my hour special.
I've grown and changed so much.
You've grown a lot since then
but it was really a lot of fun
working on that set with you.
And it's just great
that we're still doing
this stuff together.
Girl Daddy on HBO Max.
Girl Daddy.
Team Coco.
HBO Max.
And I've been your male
hostess today, J.P. Buck.
(Beth laughing)
(Beth whispering)
(Buck laughing)